تذكرت مصادر محليه للجزيره ان الجيش
التركي المتمركز في قواعده بمناطق وجود
المعرضه شماليه سوريه ليستهدف مواقع لما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وذلك في
مناطق من ارياف الحسكه والرقه وحلب وعند
الحدود مع تركيا واضافت المصادر ان
الطائرات مسيرات تركيه حلقت لساعات في
سماء مدن الملكيه بريف الحسكه وعين عيسى
بريف الرقه وسيرين بريف حلب
وعن زياره وفد روسيا لتركيا بشان تطورات
الاوضاع في شمال شرقيه سوريا ذكرت مصادر
تركيه للجزيره ان الوفده الروسي عرض على
تركيا انسحاب مقاتلي ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه مع اسلحتهم من مدينتي عين
العرب كوباني
الداخليه في مناطق وجود ما تعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه
كما قالت المصادر ان الوفد الروسي ابلغ
الجانب التركي موافقه ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه على المقترح الشرطه الضمان
عدم حصول اجتياح تركيه وان انقره تدرس
المقترحات التي قدمها الوفد الروسي ولا
تزال في مرحله النقاش بشانها